le monde s'excuse aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur light and shadow un jeu qui
est sorti il ya à peu près une semaine
sur indy db point com un site qui
répertorie un bon nombre de jeux
indépendants tout le monde s'emballe et
steaks hachés vous avant tout con il
joue ce qui serait une chose plutôt bien
finalement allé start watts presse un or
two to pick light source
et bah voilà ça s'est pas refait tout ça
un jeu d'horreur pixelisé les gens ça
change un peu c'est pas mal j'aime bien
alors je suppose que on doit se rendre
sur cet increvable bougies jusqu'à
l'autre mouche et qui est tous là bas
très bien alors remettre un maillot vert
pour partir et les monstres bizarre avec
des essais sur le front doit tant
moi jamais ça j'ai déjà perdu watts mais
je veux être commencer je pus tard bon
ok on y retourne alors falloir qu'on
aille vers la
à la lumière de la ja de la lumière là
bas je suppose qu'on aille là bas ouah
attendait mais il est carrément au
taquet smarthome au [ __ ] le gardien
quoi tu ne seras jamais eu de chien
oui et accroché que c'est que çà ou là
le bug très bien eh ben on ne saura
jamais ce que c'est on va monter tous là
oh non pas à nos appels
très bien on vient juste de mourir deux
fois en l'espace d'une minute tout va
bien je suis extrêmement fort allez
c'est bon j'ai le verre sur la tête je
suis prêt à gagner lé boyoud que celle
des start on va aller vers la vallée un
truc qui brille est là j'ai même pas
allumer la lumière si le fantôme est là
où va le monde
1 à une petite bougie ça me fait plaisir
ça me fait plaisir une bougie au pied
d'un rocher qui ne sert à rien à la
bayanne autres il ya une autre source de
lumière fois qu'est ce que j'ai fait et
si je me mets au milieu après certes au
pick up dole hier ok je me casse avec ça
une autre bougies au loin une bougie
encore une bougie bator bateau wafa qui
concourent tellement vite
michel bolt avec une cagoule égal ce
truc quoi la paillade la lumière afin je
trouve que rien à ma il est fatigué
homologue ouattar fois que je sors ma
place
arrête arrête arrête hommes cagoulés qui
vient de l'ombre je suis tranquillement
là à chercher des bougies pour la soirée
parce que j'ai une panne d'électricité
ou parce qu'on va évoquer des esprits
comme des gros connard et laisse-moi
laisse moi tranquille la bayanne bougies
et on a une autre juste là bas allez on
y va tous ensemble
attention
stop c'est bon on est à la première
bougie et maintenant on va la deuxième
couac a raté
bon à wall ag vu j'ai vu je les ai vus
je les ai vus [ __ ] le début j'ai vu il
a mis sa cagoule comme ça il a fais toi
tu es morte bien et tout et je suis
parti en courant
[ __ ] de biot laisse moi tranquille
démandé l'ombre inceste et petits
vermifuge ce que ce jeu a été inventé
pour pour soir ou pour rambo et non pour
un mec extrêmement nul comme moi un qui
correspond à cette vache par exemple
même si je ne bouge pas et que je fais
dans le noir le démon viendra et fera
moi tu as vu comme je suis méchant ya la
puissance de ma bougie qui me protège
as tu fais pas le malin allez viens que
batch j'ai la bougie tu vas prendre feu
allez viens viens qu'on en finisse vieux
démons vient mais tu espèce de [ __ ]
tu préfères à le briquet la lampe le
briquet lambris qu'elle en brique et
l'ample en brique est lent mais tout va
bien dans cette forêt on n'a qu'à faire
la fête avec cette bougie traduit
ah il arrive allez viens la puissance de
la bougie est et non
en bas les steaks
j'ai serré la prochaine fois avec une
[ __ ] ardenne 240 tableaux tata tata tata
tata qui sait que sa folle voilà c'est
le cercle de l'invincibilité j'ai un
personnel en fait ya des espèces de
traces des glaces sur mon écran
probablement des potions et du coup j'ai
l'impression de le voir là dans le noir
alors qu'en fait absolument pas quoi
alors si c'est que ça très bien cette
écriture la hd vous lâche l'angle of
china à elle arrive je l'entends par la
droite il arrive au plus simple blague
allez vous êtes prêts vous êtes prêt à
le voir attention ceci était le plus
gros bide jamais vu allez allez faudrait
qu'on retrouve le cercle démoniaque de
bordel [ __ ] d aragon un flacon
je le vois je le vois à une été là pour
moi il a dit hey tu veux moi j'ai fait
ouais gros il a fait un arrêt à l'asie
balle ses cinq co j'ai fait quoi ont
reculé la pme je suis un brin plus
tarder à rabat j'ai fais ok les pages de
25 oh ça c'est le ultimate rocher c'est
patron des rochers ici et là haut c'est
moi le plus gros les mecs à en faire un
tous bloqués on va fermer
et maintenant mais vous avez vu là bas
attendez non non sans déconner je n'ai
pas rêvé y avoir une sorte de fantôme
non mais c'est pas 14e en train de
psychoter l'ag de bh vous y avait bien
un [ __ ] de fantômes là il avancé comme
ça se fait très peur
l'avait bien vu il est hélas oui allez
nous y retournons j'espère cette fois
qu'on va le leu leu lalalalalala le
le leu leu leu à fils démoniaque
d'autrui tu est aujourd'hui en ce jour
j'aurais souhaité au passage moi je suis
quelqu'un comme ça c'est agen des mots
que je fais at en deux secondes je
prends la bouteille qui regorgeait
faisait temps venant allez c'est bon on
peut pas tuer votre course poursuite
s'est noyé au bon dieu oh mon dieu on a
trouvé la chose la plus démoniaque
oh oui oh mon dieu oh mon dieu il s'est
passé d'horribles choses ici qu écrit
j'ai tournant ne t'en fais pas jeune
démon de la sécheresse j'ai ton nom
oui tu oui tu donc la chose c'est bien
une sorte d'elvis presley avec un pot
d'échappement coller à la nuque portel
cette porte et faute aux pratiques pour
ta maison ont tapé à leur porte
invisible voilà ou alors si tu préfères
si jamais tu es pressé que tu arrives
par l'autre côté de la maison